[Music]  you may have heard that a certain  legendary longtime talk show host is  retiring yes yes I think we all heard  that Andy well I just wanted to take  this opportunity on TV to officially  throw my hat into the ring to be the  replacement  [Applause]  okay so Andy Andy who's serious you want  to leave our show and take over for  Letterman Letterman oh no no late nights  dead I'm talking about Barbara Walters  she she announced she's retiring from  the view and I think I'm the perfect guy  to take over actually I made an audition  tape I think it probably proves my point  [Music]  [Applause]  thank you  I'm gonna miss you but you are really  good at I've always wanted to be the  grande Dom of broadcasting good luck  with that